your Neurosis is not helping your
performance how different do you think
the outcomes in your life would be if
you didn't worry about them so much if
you didn't anxiously obsess and
overthink and fear how different do you
think the results that you're achieving
would be all of the concern and worry
and strife and thought loops and
sleepless nights distracted
Consciousness all for the sake of
between five and fifteen percent better
results
Hello everybody welcome back to the show
it is Episode 600 and as is now becoming
tradition I thought I would go through
some of my favorite lessons from the
last 100 episodes some stuff that I've
picked up from guests from research that
I've been doing reading and just life in
general outside of the show
so let's get into it
first one is it's not coordination it's
cowardice so this is something that
Andrew Schultz taught me toward the back
end of last year all he told me was a
lot of the time we believe that there is
a grand plan at work to try and push a
narrative or to hurt people from a
particular group and from the outside it
looks like a coordinated assault it's
collusion it's orchestrated by some
malign Overlord conspiracy but on the
ground it doesn't look anything like
that from inside of said conspiracy it
doesn't look anything like that at all
it's just individuals trying to save
their own skin and not get fired because
they have an expensive house that they
need to pay for and a wife who wants a
new car and a private school for their
kids and it is much easier for them to
just adhere to whatever ideology will
keep them in their job rather than go
against it so sure it might mean that
they push an unhinged story about trans
Story Hour for toddlers or someone
saying something innocuous keep getting
kicked off a platform but it doesn't
mean that they've been indoctrinated
into some grand plan because the
incentives encourage execs and
influential actors and the people in
power to behave in particular aligned
ways but their coordination isn't
consciously conducted it's just the path
of least resistance for each person now
this doesn't make them any less culpable
like it's it's still awful it's it's
still the outcome is still not good but
this presumption that there is a
shadowy organization with hooded figures
one of those long nose things all
sacrificing children's blood and
drinking adrenochrome and
Shadow Banning you on Tick Tock doesn't
seem that realistic to me like you can't
have it both ways you can't have it that
the government is completely incompetent
and inept and they can't get anything
done and also the government have
managed to collude themselves and
collaborate in order to stop my
Instagram posts from reaching as many
people as I think that they do like you
don't get to have it both ways and there
is a uh Theory bonhoeffer's theory of
stupidity which says evil can be guarded
against stupidity cannot and the world's
few evil people have little power
without the help of the world's many
stupid people as a result stupidity is a
far greater threat than evil and you can
combine hanlon's razor that you'll
probably be familiar with which is never
a tribute to malice that which is
adequately explained by stupidity you
could replace stupidity with cowardice
or compliance if you like but the bottom
line is that people will forgo
principles and rationality if it means
keeping their job like you know almost
everybody at some point apart from the
most staunch integral Advocates
philosophy moral reasoning first
principles people have compromised the
values at some point in their lives in
order to appease a person in power or
keep status or do whatever it is that
they need to do to keep food on the
table even if the table is very long and
expensive living in Beverly Hills like
coordination to me seems significantly
less likely than cowardice and
although it is
annoying in a way because it suggests
that individual actors now aren't even
smart enough to be part of some Grand
conspiracy
um it does make it feel less
insurmountable right if there isn't this
coordination it means that pushback and
change can be done more easily through
uh influence through
um a desire from the ground floor up
from outside of these institutions to
say look we don't like what's going on
and it should be easy for all of the
dominoes to fall it's not like the
people in there believe what they're
doing all the time it's just that they
don't want to lose their jobs
okay next one
original thinkers are very rare I guess
this kind of relates the rise of social
media as the primary form of social
interaction changed the way that we
judge people we once used to judge
people mostly based on their deeds but
in the age of social media we judge
people mostly based on their words and
opinions because that's really all that
we see of them since we're defined by
our opinions there is pressure to have
an opinion on everything problem is
people generally don't have the time or
the will to research everything they are
expected to have an opinion on so they
copy the opinions of others and this
results in very few precious original
thinkers in this way the culture war is
largely two armies of NPCs being
ventriloquized by a handful of actual
thinkers and that is from the Fantastic
gwynda Bogle and it is it is very very
true if you think about what most
people's opinions are they are a carbon
copy a a poor rough hewn version a
counterfeit of
whatever the people that they look up to
believe and you know this is true for
almost everybody it's very hard to come
up with a fresh idea what's that a quote
about
um everything is a footnote after Plato
that basically all of the ideas were had
already been come up with two thousand
two and a half thousand years ago uh and
all that we're doing now is making
slightly worse uh reiterated versions I
don't think that's quite true I do think
that there are new ideas but they're
really hard to come across right a lot
more smart people than me and you have
been trying to come up with solutions to
the existential challenge of being a
human in this world for a very long time
um and yes the fact that we are judged
on our opinions forced to have an
opinion and yet don't have a uh easy to
um the required wisdom to be able to
just manifest it on will there's another
one what was it Hill to die on let me
see if this comes up
held to Diane is it this oh it is
fantastic okay so this is guinda another
one from him gwynda's theory of bespoke
many don't have an opinion
until they ask for it at which point
they Cobble together a Viewpoint from
whim and half remembered hearsay before
deciding that this two minute old
makeshift opinion will be the new Hill
to die on and this is gwynda's theory of
bespoke so again if you are
your opinions if opinions are more
important than your Deeds because all
that we really see of people are their
opinions and most people don't have an
original idea on something because it's
really hard to come up with new stuff
and then the fact that you're so heavily
judged on your opinion because of social
media requires you to stand firm and
show fealty to whatever side you've just
like fallen into by accident because
that was what your favorite thought
leader said that you should believe
um it can make for a very messy
situation and the final element of this
which I really loved was when I was with
Douglas Murray last year in New York and
he I brought up to him why haven't you
commented on the covid situation as much
as I thought you might do you have four
or five columns a week
um I'm surprised to not see you wade
into this topic as much as some of your
contemporaries have and he said
Christopher I'm going to do something
which is very strange and different in
the modern world which is to not comment
on something which I know nothing about
I was like oh that is cool and I've seen
a lot of people since then saying
something along the lines of normalize
saying I don't have an opinion on that
I think that that's a really fantastic
approach I I the more that you can get
yourself into the Rhythm of not feeling
the need to have a take on everything
like I don't need my favorite
evolutionary psychology researcher to
have an opinion on the Ukraine right I I
maybe you also happen to Moonlight as a
global politics expert but I'm going to
guess that you don't and given that do
you really need to add more noise to
just put your half-baked anecdotal
uninformed opinion that I can do that
it's one of the reasons that didn't
really comment on Ukraine didn't really
comment on kovid because I just figured
look like there are other people out
there that are having these discussions
that are prepared to put in the work and
I'm not prepared to and I feel like me
just throwing out a completely
uninformed opinion muddies the waters
rather than helps to make them clearer
so yeah all of that together normalize
saying I don't have an opinion and
original thinkers are very rare okay
next one uh the problem of presence so
this was something that I brought up on
the fifth year anniversary to do with
that beautiful Sam Harris speech uh
death in the present moment which is
just phenomenal and then I found a quote
from Blaise Pascal a little passage
which I think explains the problem of
presence very similarly as well so Blaze
Pascal we never keep to the present we
anticipate the future as if we found it
too slow in coming or we're trying to
hurry it up or we recall the past as if
to stay it's too rapid fight we are so
unwise that we wander about in times
that do not belong to us and do not
think of the only one that does So Vain
that we dream of times that are not and
blindly flee the only one that is the
fact is that the present usually hurts
we thrust it out of sight because it
distresses us and if we find it
enjoyable we are sorry to see it slip
away we tried to give it the support of
the future and think of how we are going
to arrange things over which we have no
control for a time we can never be sure
of reaching Let each of us examine his
thoughts he will find them wholly
concerned with the past or the future we
almost never think of the present and if
we do think of it it is only to see what
light it throws on our plans for the
future
the present is never our end the past
and the future are our means the future
alone our end thus we never actually
live but hope to live and since we are
always planning how to be happy it is
inevitable that we should never be so
and this is the same Sam Harris thing of
looking over the shoulder of the present
moment to guaranteed way to ensure that
you're going to miss whatever is true
and beautiful of your life right now no
matter how big the problems or concerns
or anxieties are the reality of your
life is that it is always now the only
time that you can ever enjoy is this
moment and the guaranteed way of missing
your life of allowing it to slip by
whilst you distract yourself by
ruminating over things that you didn't
do or worrying about things that you're
going to do
is precisely that this leads into so
this is like a quadruple header I
managed to find four Concepts that I
wanted to throw together so that was the
first one that Blaze Pascal quote which
was actually really really hard for me
to read because he's writing in some old
and worldly Victorian
um next one this is from Jake Humphrey
so
um for the non-brits Jake Humphrey is a
sports broadcaster he also has a great
podcast called the high performance
podcast and
last year he came on the show a year and
a half ago he came in the show
uh and he was just talking about
I think me and him are both quite driven
and
um it might have even been after the
episode finished that he was kind of
lamenting how everything was going
really great and yet he was still
applying a lot of stress to himself and
he was sort of putting more and more
pressure on himself this is his quote he
said these are the golden years you
can't wait until you've got no stress or
worry in your life before you decide to
be happy because guess what you will
always have stress and worry and anxiety
and problems and issues to deal with so
you have to decide now that happiness is
something you're going to have and it
was that throwaway line at the start
which I Loved These are the golden years
like it's such a lovely heuristic to
always think that when you look back
these times right now will be the ones
that you cherish and to approach them
with the requisite Joy like if right now
is just imagine
that right now is going to be the best
that your life ever gets
and you're always looking past its
shoulder you're always seeing what's
coming next you're always remembering
the past you're always anticipating the
future and yet in the future these will
be the moments these will be the days
that are the golden years
like
the possibility that that could be the
truth I think
it really sort of opened up a new set of
realizations for me that's like okay
well what if these are the golden years
what if this is the best that it's going
to get and and not that that should be a
reason that you shouldn't need an excuse
to be present or happy with the moment
right especially if there's nothing
wrong
but just that consideration that look
this could be close to the peak of your
entire life
and if that's true
you really should Revel in it you really
should take some time to enjoy it and to
stop presuming that there is something
around the corner which is going to be
more worthwhile than what you're focused
on right at this moment and
I guess the the strange thing is that
only in retrospect can we see how
beautiful the present actually was
because problems are a feature of Life
they're not a bug and there will never
come a time when you don't have any
problems like
this is another Sam Harris thing where
he says what did you think that one day
you're just going to wake up and cease
having problems like completing a video
game and getting to a map or a level
where there's nothing there that's never
going to happen your problems will
change but having problems is going
nowhere and whatever negativity is
consuming your thoughts probably won't
matter in three months time in three
months you won't remember the negative
texture of your mind or the boring
repetitive things that you thought about
or maybe even what you were worried
about
but the time that you spent worrying
will have passed so you are sacrificing
your joy and presence in the moment for
a problem which you literally won't even
be able to recall in the future
and immortality is really the only
situation in which such a flippant
frivolously with the days that you have
would be acceptable
this leads into a quote from Alex
halmosi which is it's all going to end
very soon so make sure that you enjoy it
at your funeral your friends and family
will argue over who gets what people
will want to eat food will want food to
eat the topic will shift away from your
life to their lives they'll drive away
thinking about their looming to-do list
some people won't be able to make it
because something came up and we worry
about
a low performing post on social media or
what someone thinks of us are a bad
customer review or whether we're going
to finish our to-do list in time we die
like we go to sleep with things unsaid
and unfinished the only judge who has
complete context on our lives dies with
us
a reminder of the heavyweight we place
on the things that matter little
that is so heavy to consider
that people will argue over food and who
wants what and some people won't be able
to make it
and we die like we go to sleep with
things unsaid and unfinished and we
concern ourselves with so many tiny
minutia all of the the neuroses and the
concerns that we get into and that leads
into the fourth of my quadruple threat
triple quadruple stack
Burger of of insights around death and
presence and stuff
um your Neurosis is not helping your
performance your ability to be
idealistic is always going to outstrip
reality's ability to deliver that to you
so
um when I record the show I hear the
same Trends and themes popping up across
a lot of episodes in a short time and
obviously I'm the common denominator
between all of these guests so it's
maybe largely due to my biases but one
of the most common themes has been
releasing the tiller and just accepting
the results that come your way in life
so the question that I asked myself was
how different do you think the outcomes
in your life would be if you didn't
worry about them so much
if you didn't
anxiously obsess and overthink and fear
how different do you think the results
that you're achieving would be
do you think you'd be 30 less effective
of 50 less effective or five percent
less effective and I've reflected on it
a lot and I think I've settled on
somewhere between five and fifteen
percent but probably closer to five
so think about that think about
all of the concern and worry and strife
and thought loops and sleepless nights
the distracted Consciousness which you
will never get back from your brief time
on this planet all for the sake of
between 5 and 15 better results
or to invert the situation you could get
rid of your neurotic fears about not
achieving your goals and the price is
simply five to fifteen percent of your
outcomes and the thing that I've come to
believe
is that the results that you get in life
are going to come anyway your fears and
neuroses are doing little other than
making your journey toward this more
miserable in this way life is less like
a car drive with you as an active
participant and more like a train
journey while you're heading toward the
same destination kind of no matter what
you do now
I'm a big fan of high agency and being a
sovereign individual and taking control
of your life
and that's going to be one of the rules
that we come on to next so how do you
marry these two up this isn't me saying
that you don't have any control over the
outcomes that you get it's me saying
that you're a lot of the work in this
particularly applies to people that are
a little bit further down their maturity
self-development route you have spent so
much time building up all of the habits
and rules and routines and networks and
productivity tools and strategies and
all of that stuff that you've done and
it is just a behemoth it's like a steam
train and it's just continuing to move
and there is nothing that's going to
stop it and yet you still apply the same
level of uncertainty and anxiety and and
Neurosis to it that you did when you
were first starting out and had no idea
whether you're going to be effective at
the things that you want to try and do
in life
as life continues you're going to
realize that the outcomes that you want
to get are going to come to you in any
case because of all of the work that
came before now so continuing to worry
continuing to have that imposter
adaptation right the uncertainty that
you're going to be able to achieve
despite the fact that every single
different challenge that you faced in
the past you've managed to achieve in
doesn't make sense like it's it simply
doesn't make sense and I do wonder how
much of
foreign
and negative thought Loops that we have
we hold on to because we believe that
that's what's facilitating our
performance when it's not that's that's
not what's driving performance or
driving performance are the things that
really move the needle that was just
that's just your scarcity mentality
manifesting and you clinging on to it
believing that it's somehow causing
performance to work so I also think this
relates maybe to the dark side of Jordan
Peterson or Joker willink's take
responsibility philosophy which is that
it's potential to take too much
responsibility so much that you lose
your ability to rely on intuition and
have faith that the results will come
that like the opposite if you can
imagine the opposite of a victim mindset
where you believe that you have no
control over the outcomes you get the
opposite would be one where you believe
that you have too much control over them
and you lose faith in your innate
ability to just get done I don't
think that everything has to be so
deliberate and that the outcomes in life
are probably going to arrive in any case
because of all of the work that you've
done before this doesn't make take your
I mean take your foot off the gas but it
means approach things with less of a
scarcity mentality and more of just a
open
like abundant curiosity that seems like
a much healthier place to come from and
there's this really great great Charlie
Munger quote where he says at the end of
the day if you live long enough most
people get what they deserve
pretty good okay this next one I
probably should have done forever ago
it's like the synopsis of everything
that I've learned
from the podcast and it follows on from
what we've just spoken about
and especially toward the beginning of
this personal development
self-development Journey thing it was
the main realization as somebody that
had lived a very unassessed life for a
very long time kind of
going with the wind
um not really taking full agentic
control over the things I was doing and
it is your life should be lived by
Design not default and there's a quote
from Seneca where he says the best thing
is to want what is Right which is also
called the honesta and to not Stray From
the Path okay so quote blindly following
your desires makes you a slave to your
impulses slave to the assumptions of
those around you the advertisements
you're exposed to and the confused
chemical signals of your body if we
don't pause and ask ourselves what we
want to want we will spend our lives
focused on unhealthy aims defined for us
by others and the worst part of
ourselves we will pass these bad
assumptions about life onto our children
and loved ones we will reinforce these
boring desperate defaults in everyone we
encounter to achieve Freedom we must be
able to think for ourselves if we don't
cut to the core and program our wants
then our best case scenario is to be a
rich successful or famous slave if we
never peer into our programming then we
may end up being the cleverest rat in
the room but that's hardly worth
celebrating
so in short your default factory
settings are absolute horseshit and you
cannot follow them people who do will
never actualize their potential either
for happiness or success you are not
choosing what you want to want you are
not doing the thing that you meant to do
and there's another Seneca quote where
he talks about um a man who steps out of
his door on a morning and if you were to
ask him what it was that he was spending
his day doing he would say uh I I don't
know I'm going to go to some places and
see some people and I will see what
happens and Seneca says they do not what
they intended but what they happen to
run across and there was also Dean
Rickles who's on the show he wrote uh
the shortness of Life about two or three
months ago and he gives this example of
um a fisherman or a
navyman going out to see you know in the
medieval times and you would want to go
on an adventure right you could go out
sit in the ship and it would Bob around
in the ocean for six months and you
would come back and it would have moved
right you would have gone and done
things but you didn't go anywhere he
didn't have a journey he didn't have an
adventure and this is kind of the same
but from an existential
state where what is it that you want to
do do you want to carve a path through
life do you want to actually be moving
toward a direction that you have defined
and this again our desires Define our
own Paths of least resistance through
deliberate training that at first feels
tedious we can eventually find arrive at
a point where we want what we want to
want life should be lived by Design not
default
like that to me just really encapsulates
the most important lessons that I
learned from the podcast over the last
five years that you get to choose your
desires then you spend a good amount of
time repurposing your skill set in order
to be able to help you achieve them and
once you've got to that stage nothing
can stop you like you're you you know
what you want you have the capacity to
go and get it it's game over from there
but not knowing what you want to want
and even for the people who decide that
they're going to focus on personal
development first this is why there
can't be any growth without goals really
if you don't have any goals growth is
pointless because you're just spinning
your wheels and going faster and faster
and faster but not in service of
anything there's another quote from
Ralph Waldo Emerson where he says my
life is for itself and not for a
spectacle or another one from la Russian
folkold who I can't really pronounce he
says we go to far less trouble about
making ourselves happy than about
appearing to be so
like your life is supposed to be for you
it is you that makes the choice it's you
that's deciding the direction it's you
that is the person who is focused on
where you are going and builds the skill
set to enable that to happen
not spending time to decide on your
desires means that you're going to be
the man that steps out of his front door
and doesn't know where he's going to go
he's going to see some people who talk
to some who spend a bit of time when we
get a coffee do whatever like that's not
agentic that's living life by default
Not By Design
okay next one so this is from Charlie
hoopert the guy behind Charisma on
command and this is a much more less
we've had some like dark existentially
things this is a nice light one and
he gave some really great
um
advice on how to appear charismatic uh
even if you're not
which I thought was really funny and it
was the first time that I'd heard a lot
of these different conversations too so
some of the favorite insights I got from
this one was when you meet someone for
the first time and they ask what you do
they don't actually care about what you
what you do what they're asking for is
please give me any remotely interesting
information which I can connect with my
own life so it's an opportunity for you
to give an engaging and interesting
answer which can lead leave a good
impression and lead to a fun
conversation so you could say like I'm
in sales now but I did two psychology
degrees at University and then I dropped
my life and went to Brazil for six
months and I've got a business coaching
thing online but I really just want to
retire and spend my time with dogs and
start a film school or something like in
that there are so many different little
barbs and touch points that the other
person can grab onto and they can oh I I
did psychology or I'd love to go to
Brazil or I'm into dogs whatever it
might be like those those are the most
interesting ways I think to go around
um starting a conversation and it made
so much sense because when you say oh
what do you do I'm a business owner I'm
a PT I'm a whatever you go okay
fascinating like that's not going to get
them to remember you it's such a and you
you have to have a little
pre-prepared script right you you know
when someone says to you what do you do
you already know what you're going to
say so just make the thing that you're
going to pre-prepare more interesting
right you can pre-prepare it now or
tomorrow you can work out okay so I
would tell them about this now tell them
about that and tell them about the other
thing
it's still pre-prepared it's not going
to take you any more effort it's going
to take you another 20 seconds and yet
you're
like 10 times more interesting and the
conversation is going to go further all
right so
the next one
was uh how to add humor into
conversations by purposefully
misanswering questions so this has been
the biggest one that I've taken away
from it and it is like
so stupid it's so ridiculous to think
that I didn't consider this as an easy
way to add humor into conversations but
um
maybe like me a lot of people listening
take questions very literally we're
taught in schools to answer the question
as we read it in a logical logistical
manner right however Russell Brand got
asked on an interview is it right that
you're addicted to sex and he replied
and said I don't know if it's right but
it's definitely fun and
like
it's such a stupid thing to do to like
purposefully misanswer the question you
know to give to give an answer that is
evidently wrong so for instance if
someone asked where you're from and you
could reply that you're from the Congo
or some other place that you're
evidently not giving your skin tone
that it's just it just makes people gig
like yeah it's stupid but it makes
people Giggle and it's the same as with
the greeting like most people aren't
after a literal answer to their question
when they're speaking to you what
they're looking for is a vibe that
you're giving off and the opportunity to
just be a little bit more playful not
every question right because it's going
to end up sounding like you're doing
improv like you don't want to answer
every single question uh like
untruthfully you want to be truthful for
at least a good chunk of it but
trying to just inject a little bit of
misdirection or looking for
um opportunities to take purposefully
take is it right that you're addicted to
sex I don't know if it's right but it is
a lot of fun like that's him taking a a
dual meaning that could have been like
evidently misdirecting the the person
that asks the question and it's fun uh
and then
one other element what was this final
one here a tip for how you can speak
more attractively on a date lead with
your values when you're speaking instead
of saying that you have a job at a
recruitment company which you can't wait
to leave say why you're doing that job
and what it means to you you've got for
instance you've always wanted to buy a
house for your mom or travel abroad or
start a business or whatever so you're
working in recruitment Now to create
some wealth before you pursue your
dreams that's nice I quite like that
there was another one about how
um you can use negative
uh examples
to get people to see you as higher value
so for instance if
um
if someone was in a bar with you and you
were talking to them and they said uh
you could say something like
um I I absolutely hate people that don't
hug like I'm such a hugger I'm such a
physical person
um that immediately posits you as the
kind of person whom non-physical people
would want to spend time talking to but
you're already choosing and deciding to
select yourself out from that group that
was like just a really interesting way
to invert as opposed to saying I am a
very affectionate person you could say
oh I eat you know it is like I Fairplay
to them but I non-affectionate people
are just not for me like I'm such a
hugger that's that's me all over the
subtext to that is lots of people who
are non-affectionate want me but I'm
sorry I have two high standards for that
uh okay next one
uh so this is a whole Mosey thing which
you'll have heard me probably say before
to do with caffeine I did 500 days
without caffeine which was
incredibly Illuminating and it
reminded me that
most people are totally dependent on
their coffee intake to facilitate their
not only performance but literally just
their life and the quote from homozy is
if you can't function without it it
stopped conferring a benefit you need to
be able to stop and only use it when you
really need to know that you can Crush
off and on off and on is typically good
enough for most so if you can't function
without caffeine can you really say that
it's a performance enhancer no it's like
mandatory it's like air or something
it's it's not assisting your performance
it it's required to get you from
negative back to baseline or neutral and
that's not the way that it should be
like when you hear people talk about
caffeine especially or alcohol as well
but specifically caffeine they'll say
um they won't say I'm tired they'll say
I need a coffee
you can be tired and not need a coffee
the other thing that constantly being
reliant on caffeine does is it papers
over the cracks of why you're tired at
11AM in the morning every single day it
shouldn't be the case that you're tired
at 11AM you know even the most Ardent
parent of five with the late night job
and all that sort of stuff mid-morning
you shouldn't be that tired that you
need to have a coffee so
by using caffeine to cover and fill in
all of the concerns that you have you're
never actually forced to stare in the
face well how's my sleep like how's
how's my sleep hygiene am I using my
phone too much on the night time am I
exposing myself to Too Much blue light
is my caffeine consumption actually
causing my sleep to be bad which means
that I feel tired the next day which
means I need to have more caffeine is
that what's causing this vicious cycle
often on off and on being typically good
enough for most Alex's thing is exactly
how I've done my caffeine so I think
since this would be right to say
the most frequently that I've ever taken
caffeine since stopping and then
starting again which would have been
a year and a half ago probably something
like that 18 months is one day so I've
never taken it two days in a row and for
the most part I'm not taking it even
like three days or within three or four
or five days maybe twice a week but if I
have it one day I can't have it the next
and the best the reason that that rule
is so great and that's an inversion of
James clear's
um never miss uh what is it
a habit Mist once is an error a habit
missed twice is the start of a new habit
so caffeine taken once is fine but
caffeine taken twice is the start of a
new dependency
all right next one uh okay so um
I'm in a couple of uh neurodivergent
degenerate group chats here in Austin
and I saw what one of the boys posted
that I thought was a fantastic breakdown
of the difference between the way that
the World Views female self-development
and male self-development and he said my
current belief is that male
self-improvement sees the person as
mutable and the world is immutable so
you need to be able to be the best
person possible whilst accepting the
rules and environment you're in this is
in contrast with female self-improvement
who sees the person as immutable and the
world as mutable so women are taught to
accept yourself and try to change the
support structures and Society you're in
and you see this reflected in modern
Cinema that conversation that I had with
baggage claim and the one that I had
with critical Drinker both of them are
saying the same thing the role models
that women have that are being put
forward in popular media is you are
perfect as you are all that you need to
do is believe in yourself the only
restrictions and limitations and
challenges that you need to overcome a
society's lack of belief in you I mean
there is literally a scene in Doctor
Strange 2 where a zombie version of
Benedict Cumberbatch goes to a different
Universe to tell America Chavez the
female lead daughter of a lesbian couple
also South American who's never done any
training at all but also happens to have
the greatest power in the universe that
all she has to do is believe in herself
zombie Benedict Cumberbatch alternate
universe I just came here to tell you
that you need to believe in yourself
like is that really
an inspiring message for girls to have
like is it should it not be that you can
face down whatever it is that you're
overcoming that with hard work you can
achieve things and there was a contrast
between the two different versions of
Mulan so the first one the Disney movie
from like the original Aladdin days
whatever must be the 90s that was
uh I think she styled her hair as a guy
and sort of snuck in and no one knew
that she wasn't uh that she was a girl
until later in the movie and she's
failing at everything because she's
smaller and weaker and more fragile and
doesn't have the skills but she actually
ends up working around that and using
her size to her advantage and then she
develops all of these different tools
and different strategies and she becomes
better in a different way because she is
forced to work harder then you contrast
that with the live-action remake of
Mulan which I think was in the last five
years and this girl the exact same
character right except the fact that
she's in the real world the exact same
character goes through none of the
trials and tribulations she's not asked
to change herself in any way she's
perfect and super powerful already as
she is uh and the only oppression that
she sees is from the world outside and
that difference the male male
self-involvement development sees the
person as mutable and the world is
immutable The World Isn't changing you
need to change yourself as opposed to
female self-development that sees the
person as immutable you are already
perfect as you are and the world is
mutable we must rap and change and warp
reality around you in order to make
yourself feel better like no no if if I
was a girl that would make me feel
incredibly patronized
um this is linked to another one
which is to do this with this
conversation around the sexual
Revolution and what Louise Perry has
been talking about recently in this
stuff about motherhood and population
collapse so this is a quote from Helen
Roy and she says today women especially
are sincerely frightened by the idea of
becoming just a wife and a mother
American women willingly run from the
home from the Specter of becoming a
prisoner or a parasite or even worse a
glorified prostitute into the Open Arms
of the corporate employer laughably we
call this process freedom
I mean the fact that
no one is pointing the finger at the
very obvious uh how do you say perverse
incentives that businesses have
businesses that have
um impact on the media that can
influence the sort of headlines that
women read and say is it
totally altruistic to push women to
become worker drones in jobs that they
may not love to buy shoes that they may
not need to impress colleagues that they
may not like like is that really
exclusively coming from a place of
third wave perfect Liberation unfettered
belief in women's opportunities
or is it that you have an incentive to
have as many people working in the
workplace as possible like
I would have thought that there would
have been questions especially from the
left around like hang on a second okay
are we really are we really allowing
surrogate families to come from an
employer who if you were sick for too
long would literally get rid of you uh I
don't know uh here's a final one
actually as well which has Bez zero
um philosophical or existential Insight
other than the fact it was interesting
which is why women's shirts button from
the left uh 90 of the world's population
is right-handed yet only men's shirts
put in from the right when buttons first
appeared in the 17th century they were
only for the wealthy women who were
dressed by right-handed servants placing
buttons on the left made it easier for
the servants to button them up having
men's shirts button from the right made
sense because men dressed themselves and
because a sword drawn from the left hip
with the right hand would be less likely
to become caught so guys if you think
about the way that your shirt goes you
go right side in then left side over the
top right and then you button like that
and now if you you imagine that you take
a sword from your left hip and draw it
out it's actually not going to get
caught because the fold is running in
the other direction whereas for women
because they're addressed by mate also
because they were wearing those
ridiculous bodices and those like huge
bumblebee ass things and I imagine it
probably took a a team of women in a
scaffolder to be able to get a a
Bridgeton style lady put together
um but yeah they reversed it because
right-handed servants needed to be able
to dress women and it's just such a
funny example of like conceptual lock-in
that you have this thing that
vestigially decides to be stuck about I
mean we'll just leave it it's too
difficult to change I'm pretty sure I
might be wrong about this I'm pretty
sure that girls hoodies
zip from the left as well I'm pretty
sure that you need to pull it up with
your left hand which I mean like the
when was the zip created I have no idea
but it's definitely not in a time when
people were mostly dressed by servants
right so it's just so funny how you get
this concept creep that comes out over
the top
anyway okay next one okay so this was
um this was something that I only came
up with really recently and I was out
for dinner with Oliver heldens DJ that
did that song Gekko and does Hilo which
is his techno thing and he's a very very
nice guy and he's a fan of the show
did dinner with him and he asked how do
I gauge the honesty of other creators
and how can I be sure that they're
trustworthy and not audience captured
and creating their work for the right
reasons and I ended up just off the top
of my head describing a little
um process that I must go through and I
it made sense and I noticed myself going
through it and I was like oh wow that's
the first time that I've written this
down or said it out loud but it might be
useful to you as well so
first thing that I do is I ask myself
when was the last time that I heard this
person change their mind
sidepoint this doesn't actually
necessarily just need to be for creators
it can be for anybody that you want to
work out whether you think they are an
adequate or trustworthy thinker so first
one when was the last time you heard
them change their mind if no amount of
evidence would change someone's opinion
then they don't hold a rational opinion
they hold an ideological belief
like if there is no
if they can't tell you what it would
take for them to alter their stance
you're not talking to somebody that is
in the world of evidence and rationality
in the scientific reason right all of
the thinkers that I respect the least
see changing their opinions as
tantamount to destruction of their sense
of self because when your ego and your
stances have become fused so tightly
that you can no longer separate them you
become less and less objective and if
someone doesn't regularly alter their
opinions they're either an unserious
thinker or a Godlike deity with
omniscience
the second one is do they primarily
identify outgroups as a mode of bonding
for their in-group do they primarily
identify out groups as a mode of bonding
for their in-group so this is straight
out of the charlatan Playbook which my
housemate Zach calendar taught me about
leaning into tribal biases is a fast
track way to getting people onto your
side because
humans are naturally super tribal so
manifesting any enemy group to Galvanize
everyone into battle against will be
superbly effective at encouraging
affiliation however
bonding together over the mutual
distaste of an out group is inherently
fragile right because everyone is only
bonded together because the enemy of
their enemy is a friend
the Purity spiral happens as well which
means that you're the only way that you
can hold together a group that is bound
together over the mutual hatred of an
out group is to continue to find out
groups to hate so this is how
intersectionality works with regards to
some of the social justice victimhood
stuff you've been seeing whereby
um if you're gay you were part of the
LGBT movement but if you're gay and
white you're kind of a bit less gay
because you're less oppressed which
means that the Purity spirals start to
shave people off and that's the way that
it continues to bond the in-group
together Heretics that don't conform to
the in-group ideology get identified and
they get shamed so the rule would be to
check whether the people who you are
talking to or who you love the work of
you actually look up to them or if you
just dislike the people who dislike them
and who they say they dislike
that's a big difference and it sneaks in
under the surface and it's very it's
very easy to get confused number three
how often do they admit mistakes
genuinely not performatively so openness
and vulnerability is a costly signal
because it means that the person who
you're following cares more about being
accurate than seeming perfect they're
prepared to identify their own blind
spots in service of being honest and
obviously one problem here is
performative mistake Pawn is a tool that
smart charlatans can use to pretend that
they're owning up to a mistake but it's
just a smoke screen it's not a real
mistake that's actually vulnerable or
embarrassing to them all that they're
trying to do is create a wall of um
culpable uh Justified realism so that
you can't they can't be accused of being
too hubristic right
um but just identifying mistakes like it
does this person admit that they're
wrong do they identify it do they bring
it up
um that's usually a pretty good signal
and the final One Number Four uh do they
want to hear alternative points of view
for reasons other than mocking them
again related to all of the above if
their entire body of work is an echo
chamber where the only Divergent voices
are ones that they speak to in order to
make them feel silly or Galvanize out
group hatred or simply for clickbait
then they're not concerned with the
truth because not only is it important
for your and their learning to be
exposed to different opinions but it's
also important to show that you can talk
to people who you disagree with without
it turning into the sort of slanging
match that literally everybody on the
internet says that they hate to Hate so
I'm sure that these are the
problems here as well but the
alternative points of view
for instance the episode that I did with
um
David lay about cuckolding and porn he's
like a pro porn researcher who's
pro-cook holdery and like I was very
very impressed with how that episode was
received obviously it still triggered
quite a lot of people but
for the most part it was really really
like this is interesting I can't see
myself doing it but I very much
appreciate uh respectful conversation
between two people who maybe don't agree
on this particular point of view
um but I learned some new stuff uh and
and it also sets a tone right that you
can't have conversations with people
that have different points of view in
service of what we've just gone through
and not performatively I promise
um I was going to highlight something
that I previously believed that I think
is a mistake and that I now don't
believe and that is a quote from Alanda
botton that says loneliness is a kind of
tax you have to pay to atone for a
certain complexity of mind I must have
said this 100 200 300 times I love it
loneliness is the kind of tax you have
to pay to atone for a certain complexity
of mind the more unique you are the
fewer people are like you and the fewer
people will get to you this is fine
because the increase in depth of insight
is worth the entry price
I'm not convinced that this is true
mostly because of my n of one incredibly
representative life but that was the
reason I agreed with it before so I
guess like I've just proven the evidence
that I was relying on previously but
foreign
I've noticed that the
complexity of Mind thing is actually
facilitating greater depth of
communication it's helping me to find
friends it's helping me to
um
meet people that
I genuinely
have an affinity with and
um
I don't know what
maybe I'm gonna come full horseshoe and
loop back around and be like oh actually
no I was wrong that was just like a
smoke screen in front of oh that was a
trapdoor that I fell through but I don't
think that loneliness is a tax that you
have to pay to atone for a complexity of
mind I think that you can
if you work hard enough to put yourself
into an environment that has people who
are like the sort of person that you are
like
that complexity of mind can actually
help to bind you together in a really
great group so that was one of them oh
and here's the final thing actually so
this is uh Claire Lehman who's the
founder of Colette
quote from her optimizing for engagement
has distorted mainstream media but it's
just as distorting to independent and
alternative media as well if not more so
it's sad to see the best minds of my
generation destroyed by algorithms and
this is around the audience capture
conversation so when a Creator finds a
particular type of messaging that
resonates really well online with their
audience they're incentivized to do that
messaging more and more because it grows
their Channel and as the channel grows
they get more positive feedback the
Creator begins to make more editorial
decisions about what topics to focus on
based on what their prediction is of
what the audience wants as opposed to
what they want to create they're playing
the game purely to appease the audience
and the problem is that just like with
any drug the user requires an
ever-intensifying dose to be able to get
the same effect so the creator has to
have ever more outlandish and extreme
views more click bait even more red meat
for the audience with even less Nuance
because any subtlety or deviation from
the audience's expectations will result
in poor performance and pushback from
this audience that you've basically
become a simp to like you you as the
Creator have started simping for your
own audience so the incentive to
challenge the audience with differing
points of views is no longer there and
you can see how a Creator who desires
growth at all costs would easily be
seduced by this like if they would think
if I continue being more extreme and
predictable I get more positive feedback
and growth and money if I move in the
opposite direction I get negative
feedback and less growth and less money
so why would I do anything other than
just like get on my knees and sent for
the audience so instead of being an
outlet for their own curiosity the
channel has now become limbic hijack
prediction engine for the Creator's
audience it leads to hacky clickbaity
tribal overblown work and it's easy to
tell right you can
very simply tell which online creators
have become audience captured because
can you accurately predict this person's
opinion on any topic without having them
heard
without having heard them talk about it
like if the creator has become a
caricature of themselves and they rarely
surprise you with what they believe in
or the guests they bring on or the
stories that they feature if not you've
probably got someone who's audience
captured and the internet is so tribal
that some audiences are only prepared to
support a creator that agrees with their
entire worldview and the slightest
deviation from it can identify them as
no longer a member if they're in group
and just an enemy this was something I'd
said to do with Sam Harris which is
agree with him or not some of his takes
are accurate and you shouldn't
support your your support for someone
that you believe in
or that has accurate takes shouldn't
flip-flop between hatred and love based
on whether or not you think that they're
batting for your side like it doesn't
change the veracity or the accuracy of
their insights all that you're doing is
basically saying look if you're going to
say all of the things I want you to say
then I'm on your side as soon as you say
one of the things I don't want you to
say that's it everything's out of the
window look like you're limiting your
own growth there you know you you are
stopping yourself
from taking on board some genuinely
valuable and useful insights because you
don't like like this bit or that bit
okay next one uh this is the answer to
every productivity problem at least
that's what I think it's not far off and
it's John Maxwell who says you cannot
overestimate the unimportance of
practically everything and it's the core
tenant of essentialism by Greg McEwen so
for the first time in history most of
our problems are due to abundance and
not scarcity too much stimulation too
much convenience too much information
too much calories and too many options
on how to spend our time there are more
things that we can do than we have time
to do them in and the Allure of novelty
means that we're pretty compelled to try
and do as many of them as we can which
is a recipe for disaster because rather
than creating a varied and engaging
Buffet of Life options it's an erratic
seduction by everything which and causes
us to move incredibly fast in no
particular direction which means that
you stay still in relation to what you
actually care about so
you have to decide what it is that you
want and just ruthlessly cull everything
else like I I genuinely believe that the
ultimate productivity tool is just
getting really really clear on what it
is that you want and just ruthlessly
getting rid of everything that doesn't
contribute to it this doesn't mean that
you need to be some
Cutthroat monk modes hardcore like work
all the time person like if one of the
things that you want is a flourishing
social life or a great relationship with
your partner or your kids or your
parents or your environment or whatever
it is like that gets folded into this
what doesn't contribute to that may be
spending two hours a day on Tick Tock or
pressing the snooze button for 30
minutes every morning or never actually
showing up to your workouts like
the ultimate productivity tool is
something close to getting really really
clear on what you want and ruthlessly
culling everything else
there isn't really anything more that
you need to do like if if all that you
did
was just work on the vital few tasks
which are a part of your path of highest
contribution you wouldn't need a fancy
to-do list system or notion template to
hold your entire life together I think
most overwhelming busyness comes from
caring about what doesn't matter rather
than working too inefficiently and
getting distracted by the many trivial
options that we have every single day
feels like work in the moment but it
looks like a waste in retrospect so get
clear on what you want identify what
moves you toward it start to neuter
everything else and I'm pretty sure that
this is the answer to all of the modern
productivity maladies
what time we go yeah I got time for
maybe
one or two more okay so
I learned about a Kafka trap which is uh
I probably should have learned about a
long time ago it's pretty common uh
thought experiment but a Kafka trap is a
fallacy where if someone denies being X
it is taken as evidence that the person
is X since someone who is X would deny
being X it's the uh classic uh she's a
witch she's
um a human if she drowns and she's a
witch if she floats so let's throw her
in the sea uh if someone is accused of
something and they defend themselves
then it's considered proof of their
guilt it lumps together people who
genuinely are not guilty of a perceived
offense in with people who have
committed the perceived offense and are
trying to escape punishment so you could
imagine a totalitarian government that
were purging its political opponents and
someone denied being an opponent of the
government but the government decided
that since an opponent of the government
would indeed deny being one that that
person must be an enemy of the
government or hypothetically if an
author claimed that all white people are
racist secretly and suffer with white
agility and then decides that any denial
of the racism is evidence of their white
fragility and complicity and racist
superstructures that would also be a
Kafka trap hypothetically as I said and
this is another gwynda Bogle quote here
that says smart people plus ideology is
a terrifying cocktail when intelligent
people affiliate themselves to ideology
their intellect ceases to guard against
wishful thinking and instead begins to
fortify it causing them to inadvertently
Mastermind their own delusion and to
very cleverly become stupid
so these two combine together
the prevalence of the public
intellectual and the uh going right back
to the start that uh
sense of need that you should you are
your opinions that you should have a
take on everything
um
and the unfalsifiability of
like performative compliance again that
Andrew Schultz thing that all of this
you can see if you start to piece some
of the different things even just the
stuff that we've gone through today
which is like what like I don't know 15
10 or 15 Concepts
you can start to see how some of the
different
Trends and uh social contagions and
um
rhythms of communication that we've seen
over the last 10 years or so we can see
where they come from right all of the
incentives align for people to behave in
very particular ways for them to be
their opinions for them to go along with
the crowd as opposed to pushback against
it for them to coddle and patronize
women for them to to sort of
um point the finger at perpetrators when
it comes to men uh
the Kafka trap thing is this very easy
to claim unfalsifiable uh
like thought trap that people can fall
into and when you wrap all of this up in
ideology that has stepped in to replace
the fact that no one's got any religion
or any Grand narratives to hold
themselves together anymore
all of this ability to believe that
you're very smart actually insulates
them from being able to see the world
they're terrified of admitting that
they're wrong or admitting their
mistakes like all of the stuff today uh
really does apart from the thing about
getting dressed from the left that maybe
doesn't
quite make as much sense but it was
interesting so anyway look uh I love you
all thank you
um roll on episode
700 don't forget chriswillx.com books if
you want to get a list of 100
life-changing books that I absolutely
love they're interesting and impactful
and there's links to go and buy them and
there's descriptions about why I like
them so if you need new books just go
there chriswillex.com
I'll see you next time
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
foreign
[Music]